very nice to see you always great to see
you especially so tonight because you
were you you were tweeting and sending
out live video that you I almost didn't
make it here in front of my house and
the car just didn't show up and so I
texted either what texted my manager and
they texted you yeah and then you guys
sent an uber and it's sort of that we
set in ubers in an uber it was yeah yeah
and then that still cost too much right
exactly
so mail Emma raisers I was in an uber
like live tweeting in case because I
wanted an excuse in case I didn't make
it right right yeah it was fun cuz I was
in my dressing room with some of my
writers watching you in an uber saying I
don't know if I'm gonna make it to Konya
yeah when the audience is here and when
they're doing the warm-up and I'm about
to go out and start the show and I
thought this is interesting but I could
just come out with the phone with the
phone and we could have put it right
here why didn't we do that you should
have done it had done it at the time
let's fake it next time yeah you gotta
phone I want to do all my shows but bye
you see you that's time that'd be great
yeah anyways time your guests yeah
that's the way it's going to be she'd do
an episode where you FaceTime all your
guests and everyone's in bed in robes
right I mean you just do that that'll be
an amazing innovative thing to do we'll
do it you could probably know what their
stars that way guess what what bigger
stars what are you talking about dude
let's come on I'm a place filler you
could actually get like George Clooney
oh good women are you groaning at me yes
they love you Wow
they don't want to see
[Applause]
yeah also have you seen George Clooney
when he hasn't gotten out of bed yet oh
yeah a little rough
yeah little rot oh yeah
you